well
about 300,000
clark county students will not have classes until
wednesday due to a break due to the
increase in coronavirus cases how
are you greeted by cristián cáceres during
the board meeting on
thursday night leaders said this
break is necessary  They also discussed
that for now there is no plan to
return to
full-time virtual learning. Teachers are still
working from home Friday
as well as next Tuesday
after Governor Steel ceased his
announcement that the state will receive more than
half  million kobe rapid tests
to be done in your
home community these are scheduled to
arrive in different parts of the state by the
end of this month they will be distributed to 90
sites including libraries and
community centers in less than 24 hours the
videos from las vegas will be  playing his
first postseason game since
2016 is finalizing all the details
for  to face them I come from without
dinner and in the first round of
elimination the raiders have not won a
postseason game since they
advanced to super pop in 2003
however the bad guys are
ready for this battle so best of
luck and we close with the
weather forecast as we can
see we will have a pleasant day
at 67 degrees as the highs
await you temperatures above
60 for the weekend I am Cristian
Cásseres with your brief informative in
English in Spanish good day